the five most magical moves of ding
liron China's answer to magnus carlsen
will he actually become world champion
maybe maybe so we're gonna have a look
at his five most amazing moves remember
to like and subscribe to this video and
see how many you can get right a very
humble player he did actually say that
he didn't want to be famous but if he
continues playing the way is in these
videos he will become even more famous
on to example number one real skill and
chess is getting out of tricky positions
being a Houdini on the board and in this
position ding with the black pieces has
just been faced by Knight to c5 holy
Fang being the player the white piece is
extremely strong player and if black
just sits here Black Hawk gets
suffocated so what amazing idea did ding
now play well first of all Bing played
rook takes he free sacrificing big
change and the idea behind this move was
to then continue with Knight takes e5
and did you get the second part the
sequence this is what makes this a good
idea
rook takes e5 a second quite astonishing
move really trying to work on the dark
squares there and the point is if that
rook is taken the bishop comes flying in
and now look at those lovely bishops
with a very complex game but black has
found counter play after her Yi fangs
King h1 rook c7 black has an active game
the pawn is coming through and blacks
bishops could come to life so finding
activity in situations where you're
worse this is one important lesson to be
learned here on to example number two
this next disciple is one of my favorite
games of all time and we have bingler
over the black pieces what did he now
play White's King is doing a Walker
death but ding leerin has sacrificed his
Queen and you need to look aggressive a
little roll I will say if there's not an
immediate win in the position so if
checks or captures don't help then
look for bringing in your reinforcements
and trying to create threats and that's
exactly what blackmail does with the
astonishing move rook to d4 and this
move is simply phenomenal the idea is if
white takes out the knight now finds the
square and it Forks the king and queen
winning the game and this move rook d4
is not just the flamboyant way to throw
a piece into the middle of the board
it's creating a deadly threat the rook
is a force field against the white king
and now the idea of pawn to g4 comes
alive if Knight takes g4 the bishop will
come in with checkmate let's just show
that pawns away free g4 check has to be
taken Bishop takes g4 checkmate
all because of this flamboyant peacock
of a rug let's have a look at a couple
more moves h3 was played to try to hold
this idea up h5 Harry good move always a
good move renews the fret Bishop age 2
making an escape square for the King but
the hunt continues g4 King g3 and now
one more magical move here a move that
tries to force the White Queen away and
gain a lovely square and attack and for
blacks pieces can you find it really is
phenomenal
rook to d2 this camicazi rook it wants
to give itself up for the battle and in
the process win the war and again this
is similar to before if the rook has
taken Knight e4 will win the Queen and
now this rook you can see I'm smiling I
can't help but smile when I see
something magic on these 64 squares and
now this rook is ready to bring in to
have to come around that angle and
Knight to e4 will happen and black went
on to win this game you can check this
game out by searching for Dingley runs
best over games on chess calm there's
something very nice about simple crisp
technique and simple crisp tactics and
that's exactly what occurs here it's
white to play and black is ready to
block the H born by playing King to h7
so what did white
this is one that I hope most of you will
find h7 check it's actually better for
white not to have this pawn because this
pawn simply gets in the way of the rook
so give hurry up have it have the port I
don't want you Harry you're opening up
line so we can win the war there's lots
of brave brave pieces being shown when
ding Lyra and sacrifices them and now if
King takes h7 the rook slides in and
this time we check
notice how handy is not to have a pawn
there and next move rook to h8 mate and
the game continued Bishop takes h7 but
now rook to h4 and it's an unstoppable
threat of Bishop to d3 and I'll let you
work out why that is completely
devastating there's nothing that black
can do to stop this idea and to hold on
therefore he resigned crisp nice and
simple just like me not really actually
mastering how to attack from thin air is
a real skill and this is something being
luring shows in this game against
Aronian of all players now Ronan's
pieces are kind of strapped over on the
Queen side and it's these alarming bells
you know which you should notice when
going for an attack all the whites
pieces are placed on the Kings side how
do we rip the King apart you can't pause
remember that if you need to Bishop
takes g7 opening up the black King and
then the White Queen comes in with a
check Queen f6 threatening checkmate and
here wipe the song a little bit sadistic
white is basically saying I'm gonna
repeat the position giving black hope
that it might be a draw and maybe blacks
thinking yeah I'm gonna get a draw here
and all of a sudden white goes I laugh
at your draw offer and plays rook e1 and
this is very clever you can rarely
checkmate with just with one piece two
pieces two very strong pieces a Queen
and the rook can
the job as they do here Aronian tries a
takes b4 now quick question which you
mean fuel rook to e3 or e4 Riki five is
much more accurate because again it's
rookie free Queen takes a free holds on
and maybe black is just about surviving
here by giving up his queen after rook
e5 there's a deadly threat of it's
swinging over to bring more firepower
against the king and after age six it
finds a way in black cannot get his
pieces around to defend and you can see
there's multiple checkmate frets and
after Queen takes f6 Aronian resigned
very nice technique there on to the
final example this last example is a
brilliant show of how to use pieces and
divert your opponent's major defensive
pieces away from where they should be
for example the black Queen here is
defending the pawn on h7 and this porn
on h7 is something which is holding
blacks position together so how can
white do something very clever in its
little sequence I've never seen before
in my many years 35 years of playing
chess to cause problems and force a way
through to that square well Bishop to c2
and this is a really bizarre idea this
has to be taken and can you see the
follow up the follow up is the block
aiding move Knight d3 and now black has
no way to defend h7 very strange
technique there and after the Queen
comes in and now Knight to e5 black
loses his queen and loses the game so on
the surface very simple yet a very
unique tactic showing brilliant vision
from Bing glaring so what an amazing
player doing with Liron is definitely
one of the most deadly attacking players
of the current age he's also got a very
good score against Magnus Carlsen so if
he does get a chance to play Magnus I
think make this will be just a tad
scared do you think ding lurin will win
the candidates
let me hear what you think below and do
you remember to like and subscribe to
this video if you do that I won't get
fired I saw was a good start and I might
even get asked to eat more of these
videos which is good for me probably bad
for some of you but good for me and may
be good for some interesting chess loose
goodbye until next time